you know as loud zoo mentioned one day
he said
that those who have knowledge don't
predict
and those who predict don't have
knowledge
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm joined today by dmitry
gezerski
cto and founder of click-ins ltd dimitri
is a software architect and technology
consultant with a proven record of
building military-grade intelligence
systems
as the co-founder and cto of click-ins
he has two patents spending on his field
of research includes ontology
domain-driven design graph technologies
link analysis computer vision and
artificial intelligence
dema has created companies and worked
with a wide range of customers from
startup companies to government
organizations
he holds a bsc degree in economics and
information systems
engineering from the technolon institute
of technology
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being with me how are you
i'm fine thank you for having me are you
calling from the offices right now
yes yes we are ah i love postcovid
and it's it's amazing and today i get to
talk about
visual intelligence and i get to talk
about artificial intelligence is
something that is very dear to my heart
but i'm also excited to pick your brain
on
on the way this the implications that
your technology is going to have on
society
and the way that you're approaching it
and a little bit about your upbringing
all the way from the tiffany on
an engineer by trade and now
running this amazing company so diva
give me a short run down
who you are before we get to the the
amazing technology you're working on
yeah as you pointed out i graduated from
technion in 1999
then i had six years serving in military
and after that i was a software solution
architect for multiple companies
startups governments
had a lot of background in military
intelligence and
architecting and implementing
intelligent systems
and i run professional services company
consulting so with this knowledge i come
to clickings and
actually partnered with eugene ceo
who comes from insurance industry so i'm
bringing my background to solve the
complex problems using their
expertise here now tell me a little bit
then about about clicking so your your
co-founder eugene is coming from the
insurance industry you're calling
military intelligence you know very
heavy duty engineering
uh very you know very professional
fields what do you guys decide to do
together within click-ins and how do you
decide to leverage deep technology
to do something really interesting the
click-ins was founded
in 2014
with with the goal to tackle insurance
fraud
so we addressed insurance fraud as a
as much as terrorist activity and uh wow
yeah so the fraudsters in in my mind are
terrorists and they
we address them exactly as those so we
built
we started building the platform for for
insurance fraud prevention
by employing the principles from a
military-grade intelligence
uh these principles actually are the
fundamental things that we
are using in click-ins and with the time
we focused on
on the vertical of automotive so we
started working with the
fleet managements and the dealerships
and insurance companies so today we work
operate in different
verticals we do visual intelligence
for those verticals automatic vehicle
inspections
by using images only images
and now yeah i i have to
zoom out a little bit for context uh
when you're talking about fraud
and you're you know saying you know you
you have a you have a very
unique perspective on on how to treat
fraud and you know most of us in our
daily life
you know we don't experience that fraud
right
unless you're working in insurance
unless you're you're you're actively
observing it tell me a little bit about
what
what is actually happening around the
world what is the scale of this problem
uh i would the scale of this problem is
enormous it's
trillions of dollars that insurance
companies and other companies
lose to fraudsters and but i would
rather maybe focus on on the
uh on the domain that we are currently
working operating in it's
automated automotive industry so this
is uh we are working in a in a
ai playground where companies that we
compete with they
they are calling themselves ai companies
so they use ai first approach
and we are i think clicking is standing
out of this competition
because of uh uh really it's it's
understanding of visual intelligence
companies that call call themselves
visual intelligence companies use it as
a buzzword
we really mean this because we come from
this background
so a visual inspection visual
intelligence actually the way to
make ai more accurate
and um ai has
limitations okay so there is
actually i would say maybe a
controversial thing but there is no such
thing as
artificial intelligence uh sometimes
it's confused
with machine learning deep learning
and even basic things like automation
okay so in order to gain
intelligence or call the system
artificial intelligence system
the computer must think and act as
humans
and they act and think rationally
and this thing is not achieved yet so
the ai systems
vary and they depend on the training
they have
very very few limitations like
accuracy of those systems compromised
and the
security and the privacy is compromised
there is a huge bias in ai systems
as you know there was recently a hype
around this
in insurtech industry about the
bias in in ai so in order to
so to overcome these limitations uh we
use the
intelligence principles so uh
you know as lao zoo mentioned one day he
said that
those who have knowledge don't predict
and those who predict
don't have knowledge so what we do we
bring knowledge
to our domain we don't rely on
ai or on deep learning things only on
deep learning results
actually we check and double check the
results of ai
and validate with them with using
a very strict and accurate precise
engineering disciplines
like photogrammetry remote sensing god
and
so on and so forth now tell me a little
bit about the actual
user experience of this so you know how
does
your technology click in with visual
intelligence how does that actually
then get translated to a changing of
consumer behavior
whether it's from the fleet management
services from in the insurance
perspective from the
from the end customer's perspective who
are filing the claim
yeah the process is very seamless some
of our competitors
work with the video do very complicated
stuff using
hardware special equipment we actually
ported
remote sensing industry that uses
sliders and uses very heavy equipment
we ported it to a regular smartphone so
we don't rely on any hardware
we get an image from any source any
image made by digital camera
or a smartphone device and
we gain the intelligence from the image
so we build information extract multiple
pieces out of this and build a puzzle
and make the let's say the intelligence
picture
of what we see so
our detection is then backed by cad
system
so we don't only rely on ai that let's
say this
car has a dent on it okay
we have an ontology of the car that uh
running through multiple rules and
reasoners
we can eliminate multiple false
positives and we can
eliminate a let's say
non-logical results okay so
so the every time the vehicle changes
exchanges hands
in everywhere everywhere like in fleet
management in insurance
our technology will be there to capture
the state of the vehicle
and to produce a condition report of the
vehicle
and compare it to any other state this
is something that a
very few companies can do compare the
situation the state of the vehicle
between different stages
only based on images and our patent
pending technology
actually is creating a unique signature
of the damage
we call it a damage print it's inspired
by criminology
you can see the background all the time
and
this is a damage print this is like a
fingerprint of the damage
regardless of the location camera and
light conditions
the same damage will be detected exactly
as
it is okay and we can say okay if
someone tried to
to defraud insurance company for
instance and they
takes the broken door and mounts it on a
new vehicle
and takes a picture we will catch him
there
okay because this damage print has
already been seen before
so this now obviously this is hugely
relevant across
you know a variety of industries not
just the automotive uh
where is this headed so where where do
you see this technology being
implemented in our life
across different industries this
technology will be implemented not only
in the
automotive industry which is the
overwhelming in the the market is the
huge
and the actually decoded made it even
more relevant
our technology because people don't do
not want to have a contact with the
adjuster with the you know with the uh
going to repair shop they want to take a
picture and
get a quote and this will this
technology will be
implemented across industries and
property it will be implemented in
construction
because say our unique
unique technology allows us to actually
connect
between ai world 3d
and cad so we can measure things based
on
single image and let's say calculate the
length of a dent
or area of the dent or length of a
scratch
even if it's a smallest scratch on the
ferrari car we can do this
we can measure it okay and this is a
pretty
much unique because before you had to
use
special equipment very expensive one
okay and today you can do it with a
click of a phone
and the next thing it will be
assessment on the property before you
buy it or before you insure it
you name it we have a lot of
implementations of our technology in hls
industry
so we works with government entities
that trust in us and our technology was
chosen
as the best one today to
tackle special problems of them
i think that it's uh you know i can
still remember
up until now every time i go and rent a
car i have to take papers and somebody
comes with me and i have on the paper
they mark the the scratches and the
dents and i'm looking at it and i have
no idea how to read this thing
and i have no idea how you know if
somebody makes a claim
there's no information here to to be and
to have any substance it's
you know some one one's word against the
others and so
you know obviously you're touching here
not just on you know replacing
a manual behavior but you're actually
talking about augmenting it
in a really meaningful way that that the
human eye sometimes just can't
and we can't take one dent and compare
it to the other
and and and it sounds like what you're
then you know abstracting and you're
saying well this is not just relevant
for automotive this is relevant for
anything
where you want to determine the state of
it whether it's comparison across
time or even just looking and then
knowing from previous experiences
what this damage looks like whether it's
estimating or for feedback i think
that's incredible
exactly we can we can mimic the
perception of a human
and we can detect things much better
than a human can
but the computer is not tired you know
it's not
the human make mistakes and these
mistakes
because uh a lot of money to
to car rentals and car sharing and
although the computer can predict things
in the right way
but that of course they say
you are right this is this the potential
of this technology
is is great and we were approached by
multiple
players in different industries
but as a startup you must be focused on
your core domain
and as such we are very much focused
currently on this vertical
okay amazing and now give me a few stats
about the company so when did you start
what is the what is the status of it
today how many people are you with today
the company
hires about 30 employees we have a
team of data scientists we have a team
of r
d team and we have a 3d team which is
very unique and special
and we work with
[Music]
the team is distributed in multiple
companies
we also hire people in the in the
palestine palestinians
okay
we hire them we work with uh like with
this in the synergy with them and
we like their work and they think we are
very satisfied so they
they are and the uh
we have submitted two patents of patent
applications
and the more to come i have some more
ideas
and yeah the companies uh as strategic
investors and
partners design partners like industry
leaders like floma6
and the avis they are all both
customers and investors in the company
so the the
company is now i think in a
very good place on the on this landscape
i love it and they might think that you
know we're just starting to
to to talk and we talked on a few
different things whether it's
you know the artificial intelligence
it's role today whether it's a
being used as a buzzword being used as
an actual technology as an augmentation
of today's knowledge and the difference
between prediction and knowledge
all the way to uh to click ins and how
we're talking about the fraud industry
automotive but then
to real estate and property and this
whole idea of standardization
and actually being able to leverage the
technology and core mathematics to be
able to
to do things that the human eye simply
shouldn't and
ultimately you know making things just
much more standardized and fair
and especially when we talk you know
fraud
i have a few questions for you dima
about who you are less about
visual intelligence less about click-ins
and i want to take you back to
middle school or high school what was
you know what fascinated you as a kid
what was one of your favorite subjects
playing guitar definitely playing guitar
yeah i played it i had a rock group so i
played in a rug group
i was a guitarist and i also played
drums and
when i was a kid before school i played
chess and
i was a first runner up in in
in ukraine in chess when i was a kid
whoa yeah but that is so cool
by then i revealed the world of music
and guitar and
actually was fascinated by this so until
now this is my
passion music wow and who would be a
role model of yours throughout your
career personally or professionally
somebody that really inspires you
i mean professionally i'm inspired by
eric evans who is one of the biggest
architects
was a domain driven design and
architect and his book is the
best seller in in this area so i learned
a lot
and martin folder all these guys are
just played a fundamental role in the
architecture and software architecture
wow
[Music]
very very cool and three words that you
would use to describe yourself
i'm i would say i'm a technology
enthusiast
uh solution architect
that's it i love it i bring the right
technology to the problem
that's and that's the real magic here
dima toda
thank you very very much this was
wonderful and i can't wait to see what
this technology is going to do to
society
and obviously you know fraud is
important uh rental car insurance a
automotive real estate but but i have a
feeling that what you're touching on
here this
the question of leveraging visual
intelligence to be able to augment and
standardize
a lot of the things that today are just
subjective because we don't have better
tools of measuring simply because we're
human
that's going to make a big difference
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you for having me
of course thank you